was geht ab heute schon am ersten und
zweiten reihe also schon in einer woche
sind die video days in berlin falls ihr
aus der umgebung kommt noch bei knapp
vorbei zu schauen also ich bin auf jeden
fall am start tickets batterien noch mal
und individuum schreiben
es gibt nicht mehr so viele auf jeden
fall wird sich freuen wenn viele bereich
anzusehen und jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video hat rein etwas cleveres willkommen
bei einem video und zwar an geht es
heute um ein wirklich interessantes
ratsam ist aber auf cooles thema und
zwar dinge die man in einer beziehung
nicht tun sollte ich will gar nicht
lange da fangen einfach auf den punkt
eins an
falls euch gefällt es auf jeden fall
noch um da und jetzt viel spaß mit dem
video
die kann man schlichtweg lungs könnte
heute punkt eins ist so eine sache
sollte man eher vermeiden wenn man halt
nich streit will weil das ist so
eigentlich richtig unnötig und das ist
auch wirklich unnötig wenn jetzt ich
denke mal jeder von euch hat trotzdem
und ich werde viele von euch kennen das
auch und zwar wenn ihr jetzt halt hier
auch whatsapp irgendjemanden
eingespeichert ihr habt eine freundin
freude seiner beziehung angenommen wir
jetzt die seiten junge und ihr habt eine
gute freundin die spanier whatsapp im
herz hinein und eure richtige freundin
sieht das dann ist wirklich game over
ist wirklich so und ich will euch nicht
raten deswegen ich mein ich finde es
jetzt nicht so schlimm aber es wird halt
genug menschen die es anscheinend
schlimmen obwohl ich finde es schlimm
dass ist macht man nicht ww er macht es
spaß wenn ihr wollt dann macht es mir
scheißegal nächster und und zwar stellt
euch einfach mal folgende situation vor
eure freundin mal angenommen
andré setzten junge und eure freuen
redet mit euch über ihre beste freundin
also als junge kennt man das eigentlich
sehr gut weil mädchen die reden ja immer
irgendwie automatische beste freundin
view schießt und so was alles und wenn
dann geht's halt machen eure freundin
kommt an pass auf meine beste freundin
die partie die es so hübsch jetzt nur
als beispiele also welt metal gibt es
eigentlich gar nicht habe ich mir jetzt
gerade irgendwie ausgedacht und ihr
dürft ohne scheiß niemals folgendes
antworten weil dann ist auch wieder game
over dein ernst sie sich aus wie ein
fussball ohne scheiß wenn mädchen oder
euren freunden über ihre beste feuer
rede sagt einfach gar nichts macht hier
gesprächsthema weg so oder so
es ist immer besser glaube ich so leute
nächster punkt jetzt nochmals beispiel
man ist als junge hat eine freundin
meines abends weg oder so geht ihnen
irgendwo feiern kölner haben was weiß
ich
und man wird an gemacht auch wenn das
meistens anders vom ist aber jetzt neues
beispiel kann ja auch passieren ich war
gestern abend weg und darauf soll
mädchen das war halt schon ziemlich geil
das hat mich auch an gemacht und so aber
ich habe natürlich nichts gemacht weil
du kannst dich ja ihr könnt das ohne
scheiß geld auch euren ganzen freunden
erzählt meinen wege euren anderen
freundinnen also nicht freundin richtig
freundin sondern freundinnen aber
niemals eure freunde weil dann ist
wieder tot
meistens es sei denn ihr könnt euch raus
reden aber das geht meistens nicht warum
ich überhaupt zum casting jeweils nicht
das ist schon blöd
na ja ich will jetzt auch nicht weiter
darauf eingehen wir machen weiter mit
punkt 4.4 beziehen mehr so auf die
mädchen also stellt euch vor ihr seid in
der beziehung seit vielleicht gerade
erst in einer beziehung es ist so ein
monat vergangen
ihr seid jetzt genau 100 zusammen und
mädchen interpretieren da oft ein
bisschen mehr rein einziehung was
geschenke angeht auf jeden fall ist
jetzt halt 100 rum und mädchen die
denken dann so direkt war da muss jetzt
ein geschenk oder ihr wollt doch immer
direkt geschenke haben egal es ist
valentinstag
erst am 1 fünfter april ich weiß keine
ahnung oder halt 100 zusammen so was
alles dann denkt man immer oder man
kriegt auch selber als junge manchmal
geschenk und man hat selber nicht mal
geschenkt weil mein herr was ist heute
wie ein erster meiler gibst du mir ein
geschenk okay das war jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen übertrieben aber das ist
doch ehrlich so ich meine jetzt sag doch
mal hier jetzt du du guckst dazu bis
mädchen stellst du dir jetzt immer
geschenke vorschreibt als unbedingt
meine kommentare würd mich interessieren
auf jeden fall und wir machen weiter mit
punkt 5 was auf jeden fall auch
überhaupt nicht geht ich bringe sie
einfach mal so auf den punkt und zwar
dürften niemals euren freund oder eure
freunde mit einer ex freundin oder mit
ihrem ex-freund vergleichen weil das ist
auch immer aber das wisst ihr bestimmt
schon alt ist oder das war jetzt der
fünfte punkt und das ist wirklich das
ist bitter für den anderen glaube ich
stell dir vor du bist in der beziehung
und eine freundin sagt mein ex freund
war cool
blöd auch wenn man wenn man schreiter
sollte man sowas trotzdem ich sagen
sonst kommt hier wieder irgendwann mit
diesem stab und dann seid ihr wieder tot
ja ja ja heute mich wird auf jeden fall
sehr freuen wenn ihr noch nach oben da
last oder ein kommentarschreiber und
dabei ist es mir eigentlich also wäre
schon cool auf jeden fall hier
abonnieren i verlängern um nichts zu
verpassen
ansonsten geht es hier auf der linken
seite weiter mit meinem bett video das
war mit meinem kumpel seine boyfriend
parody pack das auf jeden ab und die auf
der einen seite lasst euch überraschen
und ja wir sehen uns dann am nächsten
samstag wieder unschöne stellen wir euch
noch bis samstag ordnete das habe ich
jetzt gemacht